[Musik]
immer am donnerstag wirft marinaführer
die profi pasta maschine an
[Musik]
die pasta bringt geld selbstständigkeit
und ist teil von marinas bäuerinnen
konzept
[Musik]
das bild von ihm im kopf aber
schlussendlich ich meine ich kann jetzt
natürlich sehr viele junge pühringer und
all ihre wagen dort mega viele
verschiedene spannende konzepte
und das
muss er weiß dass man nach vorne spielen
bin ich jetzt nicht sondern ich mache so
oder so
marinaführer gehört zu einer neuen
generation bäuerinnen und landwirtinnen
gut ausgebildet und mit eigenen ideen
doch sie kommen in eine welt in der
frauen lange nicht wahrgenommen worden
und ihre arbeit kaum anerkennung erhielt
eine welt in der land und geld den
männern vorbehalten war
[Musik]
sie beginnt früh die arbeit auf dem hof
kehren tobel in zürcher tösstal
dabei war marinaführer bis vor kurzem
nicht unbedingt frühaufsteherin sie war
stellvertretende geschäftsleiterin eine
drogerie
trainiert
wertvoller ist der hofbesitzer und
betriebsleiter dafür hat er eine
dreijährige lehre als landwirt
abgeschlossen mit der heirat wurde
marina vorrat zur frau eines bauers und
damit zur bäuerin
sie entschied berufsbegleitend die
bäuerinnen schule zu absolvieren eine
hauswirtschaftliche ausbildung
ihr mann kümmert sich um die kühe
auch um melodie welche bald ein kälbchen
bekommen soll
[Musik]
immer größere
spanne
nicht angst wurde
ich bin halt
[Musik]
im stall hilft marina meistens nur am
morgen
sich eine theorie vom morgendlichen stau
stau
[Musik]
so geht sie weiterhin in die drogerie
zur arbeit immer am mittwoch
sehr gern und laut dem kraftstoff
seit gut zwanzig monaten gehört auch
loraine zur familie fuhr
harry
schon vor der heirat haben die beiden up
gemacht wie sie die arbeit aufteilen
die devise niemand muss etwas machen was
er nicht gerne macht auch nicht den
stall mich das problem sie sich
eigentlich ein system oxid dass sie muss
auf dem hof match offen das schrieben
der
vorkommnisse sony
mit schafft es wird funktionieren
ich habe weder versteht was ich mache
und das auch unterstützen ist extrem
schwierig war so viel ab wunderschönen
ort und er oder partner das nämlich
macht einiges forschung möglich dass das
konnte
[Musik]
dass es so gut klappt war in den letzten
monaten allerdings nicht
selbstverständlich
ein schicksalsschlag hat die gewohnte
arbeitsteilung auf dem hof auf den kopf
gestellt
und der küste der usa schaffen
und ja so nach vorne tat randy tito
gestorben also eine koreanische
verstorben das hat gestern die ganze
nacht verhört
[Musik]
und dann mit familie mit kollegen und so
weiter das ganze keine chance bisher
noch nicht wissen wir noch mit urheber
und patentrecht auf dem hof dann haben
sich neu orientieren zum blauen was man
weitermachen kann sitzen ich werde
zeigen nicht schlechter besetzt
draußen sitzen britische marine im stau
renovierte dass man plant
auf einem hof sind alle aufeinander
angewiesen
[Musik]
das mache ich mein geschäft aber du
musst deine prioritäten
wichtig und was nicht und für mich ist
halloween und marine sicher wird die
feed oder war eine der ersten stellen
sogar obwohl ich muss sagen das hat
wirklich priorität
und andere als einfach ihnen ausstellen
[Musik]
wer die situation und sähen bank in
zürich
ein riesencoup ständer
[Musik]
der ruft ihren tobel ist stattlich
47 hektaren land
1000 hühner
[Musik]
45 kühe und nochmals so viele rinder und
es gibt nur einen landwirt marinaführer
und die neue hof mitarbeiterin ramona
frauchiger sind allein als biker melodie
die wehen einsetzten die worte jetzt
ruft bis der flugplan ist ihr verjagt
und dass man dann selbst holprig und und
dann werde ich dann noch mal um den
toten die nach dem wunsch von pattons
nach lorca
ramona hat sich regelmäßig die auf dem
hof
machen
richtig bin immer sehr sicher
der hund wenn du irgendwann
damit fehlen zehn zählern auf stur
[Musik]
ja
ja ja
sie ziehen
ja ok
[Musik]
ja
red
[Musik]
melodie
ja
ja es ist
die hanse ca
[Musik]
dass ich gut
[Gelächter]
ja
[Musik]
landwirtinnen und betriebsleiterin sind
in der schweizer landwirtschaft selten
nur sieben prozent der betriebe werden
von frauen geführt
[Musik]
der grund dafür ist einfach für viele
bauern war es lange fast undenkbar hof
und land einer frau zu übergeben einer
tochter statt einem sohn
[Musik]
ich war überhaupt nicht dafür vorgesehen
den hof zu übernehmen aber weder mein
bruder noch meine schwester wollten als
meine eltern sich pensionieren ließen
dachte ich wieso das alles weggeben
mein vater hat nie viel darüber geredet
aber für ihn war es schon eine
enttäuschung
eine art trauer dass der sohn dann den
hof doch nicht übernimmt
und viele offiziere propeller fern
das ist einfach tief verwurzelt dass der
familienbesitz dem sohn übergeben da gab
es schon enttäuschung und schmerz
[Musik]
nun ist es an welche das erbe der
familie tag für tag weiter leben lässt
der hof ist auf milchproduktion
ausgerichtet und liegt im
waadtländischen kochs lg ohra
sechs jahre ist es her dass der vater
ihr die zügel übergeben hat
ich bin einfach gerne meine eigene
chefin und ich bin gerne unternehmerin
und ich liebe die milch und den käse und
die ganze kultur die es rund um die
milch gibt es bedeutet mir auch viel
weiter zu führen was schon viele
generationen vor mir gemacht haben
ans enthusiasmus hilft dir durch den
harten und arbeitsreichen alltag
wenn man das nicht selbst erlebt kann
man sich das kaum vorstellen was es
heißt mit kühen zu leben man kann
einfach nie weg will man weg passiert
immer etwas und irgendwann gibt man es
auf und geht nicht mehr weg
es gibt keinen tag ohne überraschung
geht einen tag vorbei ohne katastrophe
denkt man schön
das ist eine große einschränkung man ist
ein bisschen eine gefangene dieser herde
ob er ohne die hauptperson epo
die einschränkungen sind umso härter
weil gleichzeitig die milch immer
schlechter bezahlt wird
wenn ich mit der milchproduktion
aufhören müsste wäre das für mich
entscheiden das würde heißen dass wir es
nicht geschafft haben unseren lohn zu
verbessern dafür müssen wir uns
einsetzen so dass es in der schweiz
weiterhin möglich ist kühe zu melken
tatsächlich geben jedes jahr fast 750
landwirte die milchproduktion auf weil
es ihnen nicht mehr gelingt eine familie
damit durchzubringen
an schöne war will nicht tatenlos
zusehen sie engagiert sich im kampf um
einen fairen milchpreis
[Musik]
hinter jedem liter milch steckt viel
arbeit an schöne war schultert diese
last allein
und dann gibt es auch noch ihr leben als
alleinerziehende mutter ihr sohn ist 12
jahre alt
es ist eine enorme arbeitslast einen
betrieb führen eine herde halten die
ganze administration die immer
komplizierter wird und parallel dazu die
familie um die ich mich kümmere
und als betriebsleiterin macht man viel
unsichtbare arbeit wenn ich im haus
arbeite muss ich mich manchmal fast
rechtfertigen als würde ich nichts
machen
oft habe ich das gefühl meine familie
und den haushalt zu vernachlässigen um
den hof zu führen schaue ich zur familie
denke ich ich vernachlässige den hof
ich denke viele meiner kolleginnen in
der landwirtschaft fühlen sich ähnlich
und glauben nirgends zu genügen
bon appétit
[Musik]
chefin eines landwirtschaftsbetriebes zu
sein ist für viele frauen immer noch
alles andere als selbstverständlich
nicht so auf diesem obstbaubetrieb hier
wachsen aprikosen äpfel birnen und
trauben in alis familie gab es zwei
töchter und aline hat seit sie denken
kann an der seite ihres vaters
gearbeitet als er vor fünf jahren
verstarb übernahm sie den betrieb
ich bin die landwirtin nicht die frau
von die chefin bin ich
auf der landwirtschaftlichen schule
hatte es eigentlich ziemlich viele
frauen aber es war nicht üblich dass
diese dann auch den betrieb übernahmen
im obstanbau war ich die einzige in der
klasse es gibt schon frauen in diesem
metier aber wenig
es sind viele arbeitsstunden physisch
ist es sehr anstrengend ich finde diesen
beruf sehr schön und man kann ihn als
frau ausübe manchmal muss man einfach
etwas kreativ sein physisch kann ich
nicht wie ein mann arbeiten darum
brauche ich ein gutes team
war es klar dass sie angestellte
brauchen ja wegen der größe des betriebs
mein vater arbeitete mit der familie
aber ich habe personal eingestellt
wäre es möglich ohne männer
weil ich eine chefin bin finde ich es
besser männer anzustellen sie können die
arbeiten übernehmen die etwas mehr kraft
verlangen
auf einem obstbaubetrieb ist das
unvorhersehbare
allgegenwärtig
[Musik]
2020 war die apfelernte äußerst dürftig
darauf folgte
2021 eine lange frostphase
finanziell war ich damals bereits am
limit es war für mich schwierig fuß
kratzen zu kaufen es im letzten moment
habe ich mich doch noch dafür
entschieden und sie eine nacht lang
eingesetzt après ski party alu rapid
danach habe ich wasser benutzt dass es
billiger zuerst haben wir gegen den
pfosten nur bei den aprikosen gekämpft
am schluss kämpften wir bei allen bäumen
in jenem jahr verlor allein 60 prozent
ihrer ernte
nun hofft sie mit der von ihr
gegründeten fruchtsaft marke einen teil
des geldes wieder hereinzuholen
[Musik]
so kann ich auch die früchte verwenden
welche mit die grossverteiler nicht
abnehmen
mit den produkten verringere ich mein
risiko ich wollte finanziell breiter
aufgestellt sein für den fall dass etwas
plötzlich nicht mehr funktioniert
ich habe niemanden der mir finanziell
hilft ich bin allein
aline hat im bereich obstbau viele
abschlüsse in der tasche
dennoch muss sie für ihren platz in
dieser von männern geprägten welt
kämpfen
es wäre ideal wenn ich etwas mehr
anbaufläche hätte aber meine kollegen
die pensioniert werden verkaufen ihr
land lieber an männer auch wenn es
direkt an mainz grenzen
sagen ich hätte zu wenig erfahrung
obwohl ich schon seit 20 jahren in
diesem beruf arbeiten das ist schon
seltsam aber es ist so
es gibt auch die väterliche seite
brauchst du uns fragen sie oder sollen
wir dir helfen beim ausreißen ich habe
einige telefonnummern von leuten die
gerne helfen
es ist schön zu wissen dass sie da sind
wenn ich ein problem habe ja es gibt
diese beschützende seite
[Musik]
hier sind wir vom 1 ich habe einen
betrieb der erb den mein vater aufgebaut
hatte aber nun konnte ich etwas aufbauen
so wie ich es wollte
hatten sie den zweifel
nun ich bin trotz allem eine frau in der
landwirtschaft ich musste mich beweisen
jetzt arbeite ich seit fünf jahren
allein eigentlich sollte es nun gut
seine hoffe ich
[Musik]
die hühner mögen glücklichsein im
zürcher tösstal
doch für die mehrheit der bauernfamilien
wird der alltag immer mehr zum
überlebenskampf
es gibt nur wenige betriebe die mehr als
70.000 franken gewinn pro jahr
generieren auch auf dem hof kehren tobel
war dies in diesem ersten jahr der
übernahme nicht möglich
schon seit je versuchten die bäuerinnen
noch etwas geld dazu zu verdienen
im geeren tobel sind es die eier mit
welchen marinaführer und ihre
schwiegermutter heidi hurra geschäften
max ist
die eier welche die grossverteiler dem
hof nicht abnehmen benutzt marinaführer
für ihre pasta
brauche aber arbeitstag sind sind tempi
als andere brauchen also das ist
eigentlich schön sein aber es schafft
groß erinnert sich frau zwei grad drin
und das nimmt dieser bereich so und
jemand mit 316 pro- einfach schaue ich
mega rock ist falsch wie schmirgelpapier
dann haben wir das eishockey ist das
entspricht auch nicht den ohren rumpf
wird der sortiert
von anfang an verkaufte sich marina
führers pasta sehr gut der treuhänder
empfahl eine eigene firma zu gründen
[Musik]
das
unternehmen hat weder wann alles so die
kirche ihnen ist irgendwer und kann es
schließlich hat
[Musik]
einen lohn aus dem geschäft auf und zu
erleben zum beispiel
dafür der produktionsrückgang ist auch
an
ja und mit den eigentlichen drei klare
durch am rathaus und der flotte
gleichzeitig auf ihren rädern auf zum
produzieren also vieles wird da wirklich
alles gaga verrechnet will alles sehen
sich der hofladen ist überzeugt dass ich
ihre selbständige business dass ich
nichts business und dann begriff ich
noch mal was anderes business und dass
ich mir nicht wirklich am kreaturen
[Musik]
das ist zwar idea for us business aber
eine eigene firma gegründet hat sie die
selbst auf einem bauernhof aufgewachsen
ist nicht
wir haben hat da einfach geschockt und
die genial stammt bikes macht und dann
ist es den job board in aber kabinett
dass das irgendwie alles gewohnt dort
oder so einfach man muss man sich bisher
dass man etwas noch legal sind hund und
dass man nicht mag muss vom hof meyer
und selbstgebackenes verkaufte handy für
viele jahre an einem stand
und ich verdient habe mit modernität und
so dass ich einfach auch im schulhof
investiert wurde das ist
[Musik]
inzwischen ist heidi huras hofladen zu
einem veritablen
lebensmittelladen mit produkten viele
bäuerinnen geworden was denkt sie
darüber dass die schwiegertochter eine
eigene firma gegründet hat ich finde es
für sie dass sie das so machen will
ist das nett ich sage ich gern alles
sich was mehrere stehen
[Musik]
immerhin hat heidi vor sich als
selbständige bei der ahv angemeldet
ohnedies und ohne lohn gäbe es keine
eigene soziale absicherung
[Musik]
das leben von france was man da wäre
sicher einfacher hätte sie sich als
bäuerin um ihre soziale absicherung
gekümmert nach 30 jahren ehe trennte sie
sich von ihrem mann verließ den hof und
ihren alltag
für mich war es sehr schlimm ich hatte
auf eine art alles zurückgelassen
es ging mir wirklich schlecht der mall
cop obwohl ja ich gegangen bin ich weiß
die ins leere gesprungen ist weil
ich konnte einfach nicht mehr ich musste
eine lösung finden dann bin ich einfach
gegangen
praktikums
von einem tag auf den anderen hatte sie
keine arbeit und kein einkommen mehr
man hat ja keine erfahrung und doch
schon ein gewisses alter
aber ich sagte mir ich muss daran
glauben dass ich es schaffe
eine zeit lang habe ich so ziemlich
alles gemacht um zu überleben auch
serviert
ich habe versucht
arbeitslosenunterstützung zu bekommen
aber nicht mal das war möglich weil ich
ja nie einen lohn hatte hätten sie nicht
irgendeine finanzielle unterstützung vom
staat bekommen
ich hätte wohl schon etwas bekommen aber
dann gehen sie es ja wieder dort holen
wo sie können vermutlich auf dem hof das
konnte ich nicht machen vor allem auch
wegen meiner kinder
für france was machen da ein dilemma sie
fürchtete der staat werde das geld
irgendwie auf dem hof zurück holen also
den künftigen besitz ihrer söhne diesen
loyalitätskonflikt haben viele
geschiedene bäuerinnen deshalb
verzichten sie oft auf ihre rechte
[Musik]
franc was mache unter steckte in großen
schwierigkeiten
nur schon eine wohnung zu finden war
fast unmöglich
[Musik]
matten sind ja nicht gerade billig aber
ich hatte sehr viel glück man fragte
mich nicht nach dem lohnausweis man hat
mir vertraut weil man mich kannte zuerst
wollte ich eine wohnung die weiter weg
ist vom hof aber da wurde überall ein
lohnausweis verlangt ich hatte nichts
vorzuweisen
so hat sie mit 55 jahre nochmals eine
ausbildung begonnen und einen abschluss
gemacht an einer buchhaltung schule in w
dann machte sie sich selbstständig
ich habe freunde die vertrauten wie ihre
buchhaltung an und ihre steuererklärung
es waren immer nur kurze aufträge so zum
überbrücken
und so sagte ich mir ich muss mir einen
tritt in den hintern geben und weiter
machen
nun mache ich ein diplom in
spezialisierter buchhaltung es ist
schwierig aber ja ich muss das nun
einfach durchziehen und dann schaue ich
[Musik]
sind sie stolz auf sich
ja ich bin zufrieden mit mir
ich hoffe es wird gehen aber ich bin
zufrieden hat mir so kann ich noch
unabhängiger sein aber natürlich werde
ich nicht in pension gehen können
[Musik]
von solchen situationen haben die
bäuerinnen endgültig genug sie möchten
dass ihre arbeit anerkannt und bezahlt
wird da beginnt der politische kampf der
bäuerinnen
ihre sprecherin in bern ist anscheinend
präsidentin des schweizer bäuerinnen und
landfrauen verbandes und auch vize
präsidentin des bauernverbandes die
neuenburgerin ist erst die zweite frau
im vorstand des schweizer
bauernverbandes
anscheinend hat über den bauernverband
eine nationale
sensibilisierungskampagne gestartet
[Musik]
dieser kampagne thematisiert die soziale
absicherung der bäuerinnen
es geht um sozialversicherungen rente
das aufteilen des einkommens und und
lösungen bei scheidungen
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass sich die situation der
frauen in den landwirtschaftsbetrieben
klar verbessert sei das auf juristischer
ebene oder bezüglich
sozialversicherungen und vorsorge das
den frauen bewusst wird dass sie das
recht haben ansprüche zu formulieren
aber
auch dass dieses bewusstsein die männer
erreicht die auf die chefs sind auf den
betrieben sie müssen verstehen dass sie
eine verantwortung haben gegenüber den
menschen die für sie arbeiten
anscheinend arbeitet seit 30 jahren auf
dem hof ihres mannes in pfronten mallow
sie ist zuständig für die verwaltung des
betriebs für die buchhaltung und für den
haushalt
die anwältin hat eine vielversprechende
karriere in bern aufgegeben um bäuerin
zu werden doch auf ihrem hof lief
einiges schon immer anders so hat
anscheinend von ihrem mann schon nach
kurzer zeit einen lohn bekommen
wenn eine frau auf den hof kommt und
arbeitet dann ist es schwierig diese
arbeit
macht sie arbeiten die keinen namen
haben aber es sind ja noch arbeiten es
ist auch eine form der anerkennung
dieser arbeiten zu sagen dort hast du
die verantwortung und am ende des jahres
ziehen wir bilanz und eine arbeit wird
bezahlt
anscheinend setzt sich dafür ein dass
alle bäuerinnen eine entschädigung
erhalten
dafür müsse man das recht nicht neu
erfinden
man kann das einkommen des hofes
aufteilen der partner muss dann einfach
bei der ahv als selbstständig angemeldet
sein oder man kann einen lohn auszahlen
an einer partnerin dann ist diese eine
bezahlte angestellte
diese möglichkeiten gibt es bereits im
obligationenrecht das ist kein problem
man muss sich einfach für eine der
beiden möglichkeiten entscheiden
doch noch gilt es den bauernverband von
der dringlichkeit zu überzeugen dort an
erkennt man zwar dass eine bessere
absicherung der bäuerinnen ein problem
ist dass es zu lösen gilt aber man will
sich auf keinen fall auf zwingende
verpflichtungen einlassen
kann man nicht einfach einen lohn
auszahlen
ja klar das kann man machen und die
landwirte sollten es tun aber man muss
sie davon überzeugen sie motivieren man
muss ihnen sagen dass das auch in ihrem
interesse ist wegen der steuern und der
vorsorge
motivieren ja verpflichten nein ist die
devise des bauernverbandes
[Musik]
yvonne koller renggli die
ausbildungsverantwortliche des
bäuerinnen und landfrauen verbandes ist
optimistisch dass sich die situation für
die frauen verbessert
sie sind total
im betrieb deutlich geschafft handy um
jeden welche abwickelt von koller
renggli selbst bäuerin hat verständnis
für die situation auf den höfen als
ausbildungsverantwortliche hat sie das
thema soziale absicherung in den schulen
ins zentrum gerückt
kampagnen können ermutigen doch es ist
nicht immer einfach ansprüche anzumelden
noch dazu wenn mehrere generationen auf
einem hof leben
familie struktur gesenkt
ich glaube in erster linie und das
vermittelte
partners gegenüber und ich glaube daran
setzen dass sie mit dem partner regelt
das ansprechen der tory die sache
geredet und dankt anderen glaube ich
immer so im werkstoff
[Musik]
ja
rucksack bariton ist heute chefin ihres
betriebes den hof auf dem sie geboren
wurde hat sie aber erst nach einem
langen und schwierigen weg übernommen
auch sie hatte davon geträumt bäuerin zu
werden aber ihr wörter hatte ihr
abgeraten aus angst dass sie es
finanziell nicht schaffen würde so
machte sie eine lehre in einer bank
es war schrecklich
plötzlich eine lehre beginnen
in neustadt von usern mit dem zug
ich kannte das überhaupt nicht
das ist viel für ein kleines mädchen von
15 jahren vor allem wenn man aus einem
kleinen paradies auf dem land kommt
ich hatte hier eine zauberhafte kindheit
dann arbeite ich dies
gab enttäuschungen in meinem leben und
ängste das alles hat dann dazu geführt
dass ich zu viel alkohol konsumiert habe
und auch zu viele drogen
2010 musste ich einen entzug machen
und irgendwann sagte ich stopp
[Musik]
auf dem hof der familie ist sie wieder
zur ruhe gekommen ihre eltern haben sie
immer unterstützt doch die zeit des
entzugs war hart und lang
[Musik]
in den stall zu gehen mit meinem papa
der noch einige kühe hatte das hat mir
wahnsinnig gut und die meerschweinchen
haben mir auch sehr geholfen
auf dem hof ist man der menschlichen
härte nicht ausgesetzt auch wenn die
tage hart sind wenn man nicht viel
schläft in der nacht es ist egal für
meine tiere stehe ich natürlich gerne
auf
und wenn meine hühner nicht zufrieden
sind mit mir tun sie nicht so als wäre
alles in ordnung und kritisieren mich
hinter meinem rücken so im stil hast du
gesehen die da
es ist viel einfacher
man muss sich nicht 25.000 fragen
stellen man muss einfach machen
weil für sie der hof und die natur so
wichtig sind taucht langsam die idee
wieder auf den hof zu übernehmen
kurz darauf trifft sie die amigo nie
ihren partner
wir haben uns auf absolut verrückte art
kennt
wir hatten absolut nicht im sinne
zusammenzuarbeiten
ich habe ihn wirklich im richtigen
moment getroffen er sagte mach es doch
einfach wenn es das ist was du möchtest
warum solltest du das nicht können
ich hätte es vielleicht nicht gemacht
ohne diese ermutigung und ohne ihn er
hat mir auch von anfang an gesagt er
werde mir helfen so habe ich vertrauen
geschöpft
[Musik]
ich war wirklich etwas wütend auf
rucksack weil sie mir lange nicht gesagt
hatte dass sie von einem hof kommt das
war für mich ein schock
denn tief in mir drin hatte ich immer
diese lust etwas mit landwirtschaft zu
machen
heute kann ich es leben
kann sich dank boxx an jedem tag
so übernimmt rock santa rita den betrieb
und tauft ihn der verliebten ihr vater
hilft mit den großen weizen und raps
flächen auch die reben bleiben sein
reich
es sind die großen anbauflächen mit
denen wir im moment geld verdienen aber
ja am ende des jahres sind wir nicht
wirklich reich muss ich sagen
deshalb denke ich schon wir müssen auch
nach alternativen suchen
um ihre finanzielle situation zu
verbessern wollen die beiden sich
spezialisieren auf pflanzen und tiere
welche vom aussterben bedroht sind also
auf arten welche von der stiftung pro
specie rara unterstützt werden
[Musik]
ich denke das ist eine möglichkeit sich
abzugrenzen
so können wir leute anziehen die auf der
suche sind nach dieser art von produkten
[Musik]
deshalb haben wir nun für dieses jahr
auch ein permakultur projekt das ist
unsere art auf die finanziellen
schwierigkeiten zu reagieren
und ja wir finden uns jeden tag neue und
lernen viel zusammen für unsere
beziehung und für unsere arbeit
mit der arbeit auf dem hof wurde mir
bewusst dass ich eine frau bin all die
dinge bei denen es um kraft geht da kann
man den besten willen der welt haben
aber mehr als 25 kilogramm kann ich
nicht heben die hat ein kleines kalb
getragen das bestimmt 50 kilogramm
schwer war hat es auf die schultern
genommen und es sicher 400 meter weit
getragen eigentlich hätte ich das machen
sollen aber nein es war einfach unnötig
[Musik]
an schöne war gehört zu den bäuerinnen
und bauern welche sich dem kampf einen
fairen milchpreis verschrieben haben
dies nach den streiks der bauern 2008
und 2009
damals schon verlangten die bauern einen
franken pro liter und damals schon
bekamen sie bloß 60 rappen
aber zehn jahre später als der
milchpreis auf 55 rappen viel haben es
an und andere milchproduzenten geschafft
sie erhielten endlich den verlangten
franken pro liter auch wenn die aktion
nur einem teil der milchproduzenten zu
gute kam es war ein durchbruch
2009/10 kamen die ersten milchpackungen
in den läden an welche für einen fairen
milchpreis für die bauern standen
es hat gezeigt dass wir fähig sind
lösungen zu finden ja wir müssen
optimistisch sein ich habe vertrauen in
die zukunft und ich glaube dass mal
betrieb noch an viele generationen
weitergegeben wird
trotz diesem optimismus und dem erfolg
mit dem fairen milchpreis war es für an
schöne war keine einfache zeit viel zu
früh ist der vater verstorben auch wenn
ihre beziehung nicht nur einfach war
weiß an schöne war dass er zuletzt all
seine hoffnungen in sie gesetzt hatte
[Musik]
ich musste ja ich glaube war stolz als
er noch den kampf um den milchpreis
führte war der moment wahrscheinlich
noch nicht reif und dann ist es uns
gelungen dieses projekt umzusetzen sei
schon so lange im raum stand und ja
irgendwie auch dass es nun eine frau war
die das geschafft hatte das hat ihn
bewegt
es war nicht immer einfach
wenn man eine tochter hat müssen die
eltern noch mehr beweisen dass sie
genauso mutig ist wie die männer
aber er hat ihnen ja diesen hofer macht
am tag bevor er starb sagte er an du
wirst es schaffen und ja manchmal fehlt
mir das selbstvertrauen aber dann sage
ich mir kommt schon wenn er an mich
glaubte dann schaffe ich es auch
[Musik]
auf den meisten höfen herrscht noch die
klassische rollen und aufgaben teilen
der mann ist der betriebsleiter und
hofbesitzer die frau die bäuerin
[Musik]
wie genau sie noch nicht was machen wir
ganz praktisch
genauso
[Musik]
auch marinaführer hat sich entschieden
für kinderbetreuung haushalt und die
buchhaltung verantwortlich zu sein
doch als eine von inzwischen gut 30
prozent der bäuerinnen in der schweiz
erhält sie dafür einen lohn
gebracht
das problem viele frauen
setzen und dann ja und du weißt einfach
nicht was wir sind zwar komisch wenn man
irgendwann erscheint oder gegen das ist
ja dann wo und damit auch zu hause
weiter ausschau
marina vorjahr hat sich auch für ihre
abschlussarbeit mit ihrer rolle als
bäuerin auseinandergesetzt
[Musik]
das mit
hoher oder für uns als
familienbetrieb und dass man die usa
ausreisen oder
eben einfach werden ich mache das ich
kann über die das parlament abstimmen
ältere ganz
unmittelbare und so also einfach mal so
ich mache mir auch so dass das immer mal
wieder stark in den letzten 100 jahren
da sind sich die bäuerinnen einig hat
sich für die bauernfamilien vieles
geändert
[Musik]
von wellnessen konnten die bäuerinnen
früher nur träumen
sie arbeiteten tag und nacht ohne
maschinen und ohne lohn ohne mitsprache
und ohne anerkennung
oft gab es nicht einmal fließendes
wasser auf den höfen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und was findet sie dass ich sie
verprügeln modell mit berühren ist
es ist nicht so dass ich denke man hat
ja vieles modernisiert im stall und
überall
heidi fuhrer hat ihre rolle anders
ausgefüllt als marina zeit für sich das
gab es früher nicht
und etwas fällt ihr ganz besonders auf
also ich möchte die cz die sätze wie
kalorien aber ich habe mich einfach mit
genau zum schon irgendwie aber dass ich
daraus machen oder so gehasst hat
einfach spd gehen auf das konto der ig
nähe oder was noch linux ist dass sie
eine geld gekriegt und einfach das ist
einfach so -
das war mal was das ist viel zu
lang ist das eigentlich wenn du
das machen oder unter dem motto be
[Musik]
mit den bäuerinnen ändern sich auch die
bauern einen betreuungstag pro monat
übernimmt wert von immerhin
dank das braucht immer bei dir für
lieferanten zusammen aber gott sei der
familie das hat sich schon schwer
verändert das wirtspaar andere
üblich rollenverteilung mal eine frau am
herd ja ich denke dass ich
wahrscheinlich schon immer ganz so schon
sicher mehr wie der zuschauer der
nordbremer lieber mal am kinderwagen
oder einmal mit dem clean das wird sich
immer mehr der von sicherheit
landwirtschaft
[Musik]
die leise revolution der bäuerinnen wird
die landwirtschaft prägen im geeren
tobel hoffen sie dass noch viele
generationen den hof übernehmen werden
söhne oder töchter
[Musik]